sandler gets serious in his new movie
called hustle where he plays a
basketball scout who goes all over the
world to find the next big nba star i
talked with adam not only about starring
in the movie but also producing it with
a guy you might know named lebron james
i'm stanley sugarman i'm a scout for the
76ers
adam i'm curious since you produced this
movie with lebron james and his
production company does this officially
make you lebron's teammate
we've been teammates i can always say
that the rest of my life when lebron and
i were on the same team
uh we shared the rock yeah yes yes it
does thank you man
do you love this game
i mean love it with your whole heart
because if you don't let's not even
bother
let's not open that door they're just
going to slam it right in our face so
much of this movie is about betting on
yourself trusting your gut for you guys
what was that moment in your life where
you bet on yourself took things to the
next level for the draft uh before
coming to nba i didn't speak english
uh coming in a new basketball i i've
been playing pro in spain for like three
four years by is nothing close to nba or
like nba players
so i take my chances i i i work out
really really good and i was first round
pick and you know i make my dream come
true i was dumb enough back in the day i
said i'm going to be eddie murphy that's
what i thought i thought
i said i'm going to be the next eddie
murphy blah blah i don't know why i
thought that
how i got that confidence but that
became the obsession i just want to make
sure i do what's right for the kid he's
got a daughter to support you got a
daughter to support
i think that you've once again like
redefined what it means to be in an adam
sandler movie with this with uncut gems
which you should have been nominated and
win the oscar for hey thank you man what
is your approach and how different is it
to a drama versus a comedy
it's it's uh it's
i just
you know what you're shooting you know
what the scene means in a comedy you
know what a scene means in a in a drama
and it's just accomplishing day-to-day
work when you make a movie
30 40 days on a set 50 days sometimes
it's just
doing your day's work and making sure
it's making some sense i love this game
i live this game there's a thousand
other guys waiting in the wings who are
obsessed with this game
we're playing a pickup game of
basketball you guys are both captains of
your team i'll take me at fleet i want
van fleet with my team i wish okay
picture this all of the characters that
adam sandler has played are in front of
us ah adam who are you picking first uh
bobby boucher come here okay the water
boy the water boy
boy yeah
for sure